[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست عرفنا بنفس الشكل مع تطور
قصته من سنه 1880 لحد 2022 فضلنا عارفين
شخصيته رغم اختلاف الظروف وفي طفولتنا
اتعلمنا معه ان الكدب صفه مش حميده وانها
بتاذي صاحبها ولما كبرنا معه وشفناها في
20-20 اتعلمنا منه اكتر واكتر كلامنا
الحلقه دي عن بس قبل ما احكيلك عن بينوكيو
في 2022 لازم اخدك لورا لسنه
1880 في الوقت ده كان اول ظهور
عرفناك شخصيا خياليه مستمده من روايه
كتبها الروايه الايطالي
وترجمت لاكثر لغات العالم وتحولت لعشرات
الافلام وفي سنه 1940 انتجته ديزني
بالرسوم المتحركه وبعدها سنه 1972 بيفتح
التلفزيون الايطالي ابوابه وبيعملوا منه
خمس حلقات كل حلقه مد وبيقولوا ان كان يا
مكان كان في طفل مصنوع من الخشب وله انف
طويله كل ما يكدب بتطول اكتر وله مغامرات
كتير هيتعلم خلالها قيم مختلفه ويمر الوقت
وتيجي ديزني سنه 2022 ويقرروا ويعملوا
النسخه الحيه من نوكيو فيا ترى ايه
الحكايه المره دي في قريه ايطاليه سنه
1895 بيدخل صرصار متشرد اسمه جيميني لمنزل
حفار خشب مسن اسمه
بيعيش مع اوضته الاليف والسمكه الذهبيه
كريو وفي الليله اللي بيوصل فيها بيكون
خلص شغله على دميه متحركه شبه ابن المتوفي
مسمى الدميه دي بينوكيو قبل ما ينام بيشوف
نجم وبيتمنى امنيه وبالفعل بتتحقق وبيدب
النجم الحياه بطريقه سحريه وقتها توصل
للجنيه الزرقاء اللي هتقول له ان كل ما
يتصرف بشجاعه وصدق هيقدر يكون ولد حقيقي
ولازم يكون عنده ضمير ولانه ما عندوش ضمير
لانه مش مخلوق حقيقي بتستعين الجنيه علشان
يكون ضمير بينوكيو ويعلموا الصح من الغلط
لما بيصحى بيتفاجئ ان بينوكيو على قيد
الحياه في الاول هيتصدم لكن بعدها هيفرح
جدا جدا ولاني بيتعامل مع بينوكيو كطفل
حقيقي فبيبعتوا المدرسه وهو رايح المدرسه
هيشوفه انصت وجدعون بيقنعوا بينوكيو انه
لازم يعيش حياه المشاهير علشان يكون ولد
للاسف بينوكيو بيصدقهم لكن الثعلب كان
بيخطط يبيعه لسيد
بمساعده طائر نورس اسمها صوفيا بيوصل
وبيقول له ان هو لازم يفضل يروح المدرسه
لكنه بينوكيو بيعمل كده مدير للمدرسه
بيقوم بطرد بينوكيو لانه دميه وقتها بيحزن
جدا في نوكيو وبيروح فعلا وللاسف مش هيقدر
يساعده لانه انصت هيحبسه في برطمان بعد
اختفاء بيخرج
للبحث عنه وللاسف مش بيلاقوه فبيرجعوا
البيت وهم الحزن على الجانب الاخر في مسرح
ودميتها سفينه بيقدم عرض مميز للجمهور لكن
في النهايه بيحبسوا في قفص علشان يمنعوا
من الخروج تحت اي ظرف فبيان بتحاول تهون
عليه لكنه بيفضل حزين وفي الوقت ده بيمر
مسرح ترامبلي من جنب البرطمان اللي اتحبس
فيه وبيقدر يدخل العربيه وبيحاول يساعد في
نوكيو على الهروب وكل ده عن طريق ان هو
يفضل يقول كذبه صغيره وكذبه تانيه وكسبه
تانيه وكذابات كتير فبتطول مناخيره
وبالفعل بينجحوا في ده وبيهربوا
على شخص كبير بيسوق عربيه كلها اطفال
واخدهم لجزيره بليجر وفي الجزيره دي
الاطفال مسموح لهم لكل الحاجات اللي
بيتمنعوا منها بنوكيو بيروح معاهم وبيتعرف
على لامب ويك وبيدخل الجزيره لكن مجرد ما
بيدخلها بيتضايق جدا من سلوكيات الاطفال
لانها تصرفات مش صح ومليانه وحشيه وفي
الوقت اللي بينوكيو بيكتشف جيمنج اكتشاف
خطير ان الاطفال لسلوكهم بيتحولوا لحمير
بيتباعوا المانجا بالملح وفي الوقت ده
بيشوف بينوكيو وهو بيتحول لحمار وبينوكيو
بدا يظهر له ديل وودنه حمار وكالعاده
بينقذوا اليمني وبيوصلوا لبر الامان
وبيرجعوا لكن للاسف مش بيلاقوه وبيقابلوا
صديقتهم صفيه اللي بيعرفوا عن طريقها لما
عرف ان الجزيره باع كل ساعاته واشتري قارب
علشان يروح يرجع بينوكيو وفي الوقت ده
بيقرر يرجع هناك علشان يلحق جبته وفي
طريقه له هناك بيقابل صديقته فبينا مع
سبينا وبيحكوا له ان عائله
وقتها بيعرضوا عليه ان هو ينضم لهم لكنه
بيرفض لان هدفه انقاذ والده دافع الحميد
بيخلي ديل حمار وودنه ويختفوه وبتبدا رحله
في البحر وبالفعل وصلوا في القارب وبمجرد
ما اجتمعوا ابتلعهم وحش البحر العملاق
مانستر لكن في نوكيو بيعمل خطه علشان
الوحش
ويخرجوا وده اللي حصل فعلا وبتنجح خطه
بيعتقد بينوكيو ان والده مات وبيحزن جدا
وبمجرد ما نزلت دمعه سحريه من عينه على
جيبيته بيرجع للحياه بيرجع بينوكيا للبيت
ويبدو ان اطراف بينوكيو بدات تتحول لانسان
وتوته توته خلصت الحدوته الحقيقه الحكايه
مهما اتحكت دلوقتي وسمعتها مني ما احتاج
تشوف الفيلم وتستمتع بكل تفاصيله وتتعلم
من ازاي تكون ذو قيمه وتتعلم من التخلي عن
كل حاجه لانقاذ اللي بنحبهم ده اهم حاجه
لان كل حاجه بتتعوض اللي بنحبهم مش
بيتعوضوا اما عن ما وراء فهو من اخراج
روبرت
وانتاج والد ديزني
كان بيكتب سيناريو فيلم في ابريل سنه 2015
لكن تم استبداله بكريس في مايو سنه 2017
وعلى الرغم من القصه جميله لكن الفيلم لما
تعرض في 8 سبتمبر سنه 2022 بواسطه كجزء من
ديزني اخد ملاحظات سلبيه بشكل عام من
الانقاذ لان هم كانوا شايفين ان الفيلم
بيفتقر للسحر اللي كان موجود في 1940
الفيلم اخد ست ترشيحات لجائزه جولدن بما
في ذلك اسوا فيلم واسوا ممثل في النهايه
لازم تشوف الفيلم وتكون رايك الشخصي شوف
الفيلم دلوقتي واستناني الحلقه الجايه في
فيلم جديد من بودكا الافلام المقدمه من
العربيه
[موسيقى]